and
it it feels like another day another
conservative party scandal it's a party
now that is mired in
sleeves we've
seen the deputy chief whip resign from
his role in government but he still has
the conservative
whip there seems to be a sense of
brushing it under the the carpet and
there are real questions about how
the deputy chief whip got his job in the
first place given that he'd previously
had to resign from government due to
similar allegations it just isn't good
enough from the conservative
party
but this isn't just a problem with the
conservative party is there and we
understand uh that there are potentially
dozens of people being investigated or
have been accused of uh this type of
behavior including uh it's reported to
members of the shadow cabinet as well
well there's independent uh complaints
process set up to to to look at all uh
allegations but the reality is is that
we had two by-elections just last week
one because a conservative member of
parliament was convicted of child sex
assault and another because a
conservative mp was caught watching
pornography
whilst in the house of commons chamber
there's very very real questions for the
conservative party to answer but we face
some very real challenges in the country
at the moment there's a cost of living
crisis and it feels like the government
is so busy lurching from scandal to
scandal that actually they're not fit to
govern
it could be an opportunity for labour
though couldn't it um could labour
win a by-election in uh chris pincher's
seat of tamworth of the 19 000
conservative majority
well
we'd have to see what happens if and
when there is a by-election at the
moment chris pincher is uh
it seems to be keeping the conservative
whip and staying as an mp
the the fact that uh he's keeping the
the whip he's not being suspended from
the conservative party i think speaks
volumes it looks like the conservative
party are trying to sweep this under the
carpet and that isn't good enough
we're expecting to hear back i think
from
durham police about
this investigation into kierstama
if
he is fined and therefore resigns as he
said he would do you have a plan in
place if the prime minister calls a snap
election
well look
i don't think that that kirk will be
fined but durham police obviously need
to carry out their investigation
uh ki has done the the decent thing and
said that if he is fined that he will
resign contrast that to the prime
minister who has been fined but remains
in
office i think the whole country is
shocked by the images of the reports of
the party of the parties in downing
street the labour party will be ready
for a general election whenever that
is called this is a conservative that
has run out of ideas that isn't fit to
govern uh we are ready to take on that
challenge
but do you have a plan though is what
i'm asking if you lose your leader it's
not the best position is it to be
fighting a general election is there a
plan in place well i'm confident that we
won't lose our uh leader but uh whenever
there is a general election we will be
ready to to to fight it
um
the metropolitan police in special
measures um
i'm wondering
what you would do to reform
the police
the metropolitan police uh i have got so
many questions to answer they have lost
uh the confidence of uh the the public
um there has been
issue after issue around letting women
down
and women feeling unsafe on the streets
of london
due to misogyny
the awful case of sarah everard and it
simply isn't good enough the home
secretary uh has had months and months
and months to get to grips with this by
uh setting high standards it's clear
it's sorry to interrupt it is clear that
it's not good enough that's why they're
in special measures i'm just wondering
what your plan would be to reform it
well you need very uh
strength and rules around whistleblowing
um
around standards and around vetting all
of those things labour have called on
the home secretary to introduce but the
homestead she's failed to do so we've
also faced a decade of austerity with
police numbers being uh cut again
something that we have repeatedly called
on the home secretary to look at
should they reexamine the parties in
number 10 and downing street sorry in
downing street and whitehall
look the
that's a matter for
the police but i think that you know the
people have been incredibly shocked with
what they have seen from downing street
whilst the
public were sticking by the rules making
huge sacrifices uh i've had constituents
contact me
about not being
fathers not being there for the birth of
their children
family members not being able to say
goodbye to
loved ones
the public are rightly outraged by the
fact that whilst that was going on there
were parties taking place in downing
street the prime minister has been
we know all of that i'm just wondering
whether you would be calling us part of
the special measures the metropolitan
police has been told it hasn't done its
job on a number of things properly um
would you be calling for that to be
re-examined those parties well i think
we need to look at that really uh
closely in the the next few uh weeks um
to see if mistakes were made we need to
get a new met commissioner in place uh i
want to see a reforming commissioner
in place to clear up the mess in the met
to restore public confidence and make
sure that if mistakes have been made
they are put right but we need to get
that reforming new mech commissioner in
place uh to do that
and finally there seems to be some
ambivalence in your party uh about the
many strikes taking place uh what is
your personal position do you support
them
the issue on the strikes is
really a government failure to get round
the the table we saw the rail strikes
last week the government should have
been in those negotiations with the rail
companies with the unions and instead
they said we're not going to
do that no one wants to see
strikes take
your place because uh many of your
colleagues don't agree on this so i'm
interested to know your position do you
support the strikes
well look i support
the public um and i uh i don't think
that
taking sides
is the right way forward actually what
we want to see is workers paid fairly
for the work that they do and a
government that is willing to get a
settlement so that the public don't see
uh just uh disruption to their uh
journeys certainly what i wouldn't do is
the government's approach which is to
say let's uh rip up the the rules uh
around uh striking um
because you you want to be the governing
party and to govern is to choose so you
need to be able to take a side dude
the negotiation
and stop the strikes from taking place
if you see what's happened in wales
where we do have a labour government
there wasn't a rail strike because the
labour government in wales was ign was
able to get around the negotiation table
and reach a settlement and that's what
you get when you have a labour
government but the fact is they are
happening and i still don't understand
what your position is or indeed whether
you support colleagues who support the
strikes
we support working people and we support
the public i don't think taking sides is
the the right uh approach this all could
have been avoided if the government had
got around the negotiating uh table and
they they they haven't uh and that is a
failure of this uh government
all right ellie reeves i still don't
know your position on strike so it's
good to talk to you this morning thank
you very much